[Music]
pewdiepie today
is a special day
[Music]
we hate 106 million subscribers
the tower of tambourine girl
ever so strong oh
oh you see how good that fit
[Music]
where's the flex tape thank you to
everyone who subscribed
we're gonna reach the moon we're going
to reach the sky god
damn it you subscriber power of
tambourine grows ever stronger
[Music]
nicer oh
yes yes yes yes yes yes
top comment decides what goes on top
thank you 406 baby feels good man
you [ __ ] today we're watching dating
coach
reacts to felix and marcia jumper
dating coach eh all right well just see
about that all right i'm actually
curious i've never seen this video
uh let's jump into it first we're gonna
relive it
station oh this is so adorable they're
first first first messages i didn't
think they were gonna show this
this is so cute
[Music]
why does he sound so patronizing yeah it
was cute
yeah it was cute as hell my name's
anthony restanello i am a social and
relationship coach i've been doing it
since 2005 and today
i have been asked to react to the
relationship the beautiful relationship
between
a pewdiepie and marzia his
wife now i think felix
my name is phil mice is dating pewdiepie
wait a minute
might see a married pewdiepie but
no pewdiepie's uh
name is felix is that right okay i'm
just gonna call him felix for the rest
of the episode whether it is rather it
isn't
okay it we're in the clear how's it
going bro
oh my god this is old school dude
what are you doing what the hell
these voices that i used to do that i
don't do i do anymore it's so crazy
anyway here's my girlfriend a lot of you
have been
begging to see her um so she's in my
videos finally
and we would just want to say merry
christmas
[Music]
i'm staying here with master's family
for two weeks so
no not that many videos for a while i'm
sorry
if you want we will probably make more
videos together
i'm pretty sure they wanted all my
brother
how was i a youtuber i cannot talk
properly i'm sure they want uh
martin's italian is so thick too if you
want you can make more videos with me
and i make a pasta with the pizza did i
mention
i mean i sound swedish too so i guess i
shouldn't complain
i love how pewdiepie keeps in all of the
mistakes that he makes when he's talking
uh it really adds to who he really is
believe it or not youtubers i won't name
any names
but uh what where's it going videos and
they cut
them but they cut them out
attractive and cool and sleek and
perfect pewdiepie doesn't seem to be
doing that which i admire we are not
going to recreate how we first
yeah thanks editor for always making me
look so
sweet and epic i'm kidding scythe you're
the best
you're adorable i'm so what do you say
in the beginning i don't remember
i'm gonna
and it's been you know more than six
years but we went through
so much scrolling in facebook my god
we talked way too much i love how you
can tell how different our presence in
front of the camera has become
uh compared to the other clip like both
of us really improved it
at the speaking public speaking i guess
not okay some very cringeable ones in
between like
i didn't see it
[Laughter]
so for those who don't know this video
is uh i don't know
what it was exactly but uh we found our
first messages
that's why yeah the very first messages
okay well you wrote me first let that be
known
i thought we met in may 30 june
yeah thursday i thought for sure we met
in may well
i wrote you're awesome i love you
thanks i'm not that great what the hell
hell yeah i am best for my dm wow
haha thanks i'm not that great but i'm
glad you do smiley face 2011. damn
italy right away i don't know why i
would think that you would have
been there but i was trying to oh this
is so adorable they're
first first first messages i didn't
think they were going to show this this
is
so cute and i love how she is the
pursuer
in this relationship right now yeah she
was
a little shark a little pasta shark came
out of the waters come to brazil
i haven't but i want to one day eight
uh i'm guessing that's where you're from
yes the last year i went two days in
sweden
it's full of trees see yawning yes
the last year i went two days in sweden
it's full of trees but
sorry if i don't speak english english
with an s-c-h
and then oh okay i don't think i've
spoken
wait i need i don't think i've spoken to
any italian girl before
are every are everyone are everyone as
pretty as you
i'm surprised wow yeah yeah that's right
i just made a dating code coaching go
wow
because i got games yeah
wow that's pretty forward for the first
couple messages for felix's
pewdiepie what's his real name hell yeah
for felix
[Music]
especially being somebody that
has a big name and i don't know wait
what big he was back
i had like a thousand subs with the no
wait
what does he think this was there but
i'm sure he had at least a million
subscribers
oh so you thought it was weird that i
just went in right away
if i had like a couple million subs the
fact that he was responding
in an interesting that was beyond just
friends so
quickly is interesting to me yeah cause
you were wrong
mr coach do your math i mean do your
research
coach good sign you saying huh
do you think that was rude of me not
even chuckle huh all right
tough crowd got it
[Music]
thanks i guess there's much more to
visit but i didn't stay there a lot
because i was going to norway
maybe if i come back you can't hear what
is it
oh cool i love norway well i'm clearly
just trying to get in on this if i
said that you go for skiing hi
sure um elizabeth is always a popular
place to go
plus it's like five minutes from where i
live how old are you
i guess i wanted to know yeah that
sounds pretty nice i'm 21 how about you
i'm 18. i'm like hell
yes i wonder how many times
pewdiepie has actually gone on dates
with
his subscribers before he met marzia was
this a first-time thing for him was this
new to him
all i know is the conversation between
them was so
adorable and it was romantic from the
get-go i thought maybe they were like
chatting about video games as friends
for a while and then somebody talked
about visiting each other
and it was kind of cute and innocent but
no they got right to the point pretty
quickly
which i it's cute i like it what are you
doing
hmm yeah i was more curious what a
dating coach think about
yeah being pretty straightforward that
you're into someone right away
yeah i don't like to beat around the
bush it's a waste of time you like
someone
you you should not acknowledge it at
least somehow
otherwise you get stuck in the friend
zone and trust me that my dudes
you in there you ain't getting out
better make it clear right away hey girl
i want you work for me then does marxian
get recognized
by now we don't really leave the house
don't leave the house no when it's
really like in busy days or busy times
but if we do go out when it's like a
weekend for example
i think maybe a few times a day but not
as much as a year
usually when someone recognizes me or us
they'll come to me first and then
they're like
let's see you can too in the daily it
happens the opposite
at the blue lagoon yeah the person came
to me
yeah oh yeah she did
[Laughter]
uh being here you're welcome but also
for being
my future wife of course everyone is
invited to the wedding
check your ring check your inbox
everyone that subscribes
are invited it's gonna be lit we're not
giving out any details right you're just
inviting me but you're invited
[Laughter]
i don't know why it's so funny i'm
laughing at my own jokes this guy is
just like
poker face half the time
all right they're just i mean there's
really nothing left to say
they're an adorable couple they go
together
incredibly well and i just want to head
this home
one last time and i don't want you to
get involved but this is so important to
me because
like i said this has changed so many
people's lives lana rhodes
would never want to go for pewdiepie
who lana rhodes
is that what some e girl
i would probably not be found attractive
in a lot of circles i mean like let's
let's put aside the fact
he's incredibly famous put him with 500
000 subscribers you know
not really well known and he goes into
some
random sports bar in new jersey put him
in like a business networking event
somewhere in idaho i don't know
his personality may just seem too weird
for those people too
out there uh interested in video games
and pokemon and like
isn't that for kids or something a lot
of people could see him that way and say
hey
i mean you're kind of you're not like
ugly but like
that cool man a lot of
women a lot of people could see him like
that
pewdiepie doesn't go in those worlds
pewdiepie doesn't value
those worlds felix goes to places and he
hangs with the people
that he values i feel like i just
listened to the most elaborate way
of someone telling me i'm a loser virgin
but uh i'm
uh yeah
[Laughter]
he was literally selling hot dogs for
labor when she messaged him oh that's
right
i was oh man who's this felix guy
messaging martial we need to tell pierce
no you could say yeah he had millions of
subscribers
he was really big and that's why marzah
was initially attracted to him
and i would say no what i would really
say is
felix made videos that he was interested
in
and he attracted people that were
interested in similar things
that also god he spent so much time on a
point that is just
completely wrong you don't have to start
a youtube channel
there's so many other avenues to give
value to the world and
find people that connect with you in
similar
ways i mean it does make a good point
yeah it's easier to find someone uh if
you enter the circles of the kind of
people
that you are comfortable with it's much
easier to find someone that you like and
you don't have to pretend to be someone
else
to sort of get uh girls if that's the
goal or guys or whatever you know i'm
saying
you like the peepee of the poopy i ain't
judging you
bro bro bro b
i he's actually has a good point i
remember that especially when i was um
younger it's like i was never really a
party guy but i kind of felt like i had
to be
to get girls let's get rips that's where
you meet them so it's like oh i love the
party yeah
i love to do all this [ __ ] you pretend
you're someone else
um but it's not going to be a long
long-lasting relationship doing that
youtube is just one avenue for doing so
and that's the way that felix did and
that's the way that
marzia met felix that's about it for
today guys
oh my god he made such a long point that
is so wrong
you share those interests with those
people you are
naturally going to fall into
relationships with people that you're
attracted to
i don't think me and martin necessarily
shared that many interests when we met
we both love japan
and that's something that we found that
we love uh
together love our pugs i didn't used to
love pugs or something that she
introduced to me
we've been watching a lot of dating
shows lately and i keep thinking how
stupid it is for people to have these
criterias of who they want to meet
because it's like if you really like
someone you're not going to give a [ __ ]
about
these criterias and it doesn't work the
other way around
he has to be taller than me he has to
have a bigger nipples than me
he has to like if you really like
someone it doesn't matter
it really doesn't i think the the
since uh dating coach didn't go into
much detail i think that
the biggest uh tip i can give from me
and marci's relationship is just being
honest with each other
100 and um talk to each other
and be epic yeah i'm not good at giving
advice
that's it that's reacting to dating
coach thanks again for 106 million subs
very epic and i see you guys next time
pedo children of
nine parts it's time to raise what was
once forgotten
what creatures fart spells and poop
troops awaits
poopty is coming to
nintendo's switch
and remember it has a very big pp
pre-order promotion i mean
[Music]
foreign